the first week of school underway but as
teacher positions remain open sub
teachers administrators scrambling to
take on the job candice charles spoke to
parents that are really concerned about
their child's education
[Music]
at the clark county school district
continues to deal with a teacher
shortage that left more than 1300
vacancies parents and students are
starting to feel the fallout during the
first week of school they just kind of
sat in the classroom
and
handed out papers there was no welcome
letter sent home to karina azuro from
her son ralph medina's new fifth grade
teacher that's because he didn't have
one it just makes me feel you know
scared and sad the school district
reports about 1100 substitutes on the
first day of school administrators feel
the remaining open positions including
at ralph's school it is concerning for
parents because they want to make sure
their child gets the best education
maria nee says with the clark county
education association tells me the first
day of school is challenging for any
educator but for substitutes it can be
even harder there are educators who
support substitutes and try to help them
out so that they're prepared for the
first day of school but ultimately
everyone is busy in the meantime the
district and parents hope they feel open
spots sooner rather than later we're
just going to do everything we can if
they could
you know do whatever they need to do to
keep teachers at our schools
because these kids are our future the
school district says they're continuing
to process more new teachers but they
didn't say how many and they didn't say
how long that process would take of
course we will be continuing to look
into this story stick with us right here
on air online and on social for the
latest for now i'm candice charles live
local now